i'm impressed by this because during the
pandemic
so many stand-up comedians are saying
well i can't work i can't go to a club
you've been picking some really unusual
venues you've been doing stand-up
we have a picture here of you on a porch
where is this is this
uh l.a or where are you that it was
somewhere near
usc i think you're usc yeah but i was
crap crowd looks uh well i can't really
i can't tell if you're bombing there or
what you can't tell what's happening
it was okay it was okay uh-huh it was a
a lady a nurse who works at cedars
i she she reached out and i
you know i said i would perform it for
front lawn and those were a few of her
neighbors that came by
that's nice i bought yes i bought a
little speaker and
and a microphone from guitar center and
i said let's
do this and i went i told i i performed
at a baseball park once um
in a tree house oh yeah we have a
picture
what's happening here because here you
are in a tree house performer
again i can't tell how it's going over
but this is like a
slightly better venue to me so this was
this was great because two things
performing in a tree house brought the
kid energy even more alive
in my jokes you know and uh and then uh
that height level you know being above
so high gave me a lot of power
right yeah you you look like you could
be a stand-up or a uh a dictator
you look like you could be a a cruel
arbitrary dictator who works with a
little
is that is that a little girl you're
you're doing
who is who is your co-star in this oh
that now that was
so my friend cindy that's her daughter
leona and that's her
leona's tree house so she was of course
like who's this
person up here in my treehouse so she
stood by me like a little bodyguard
[Laughter]
he looks like you're hyped man you know
just there to like go yep uh-huh that's
right preach
tell it that looks like fun though it
was really that was my favorite that was
so fun
so when do you guys i want to make sure
i get the word out because you start up
again
uh start out live returns october 3rd
october 3rd
at 11 30 on nbc uh
melissa thank you so much it really is
it really is a joy to talk to you and um
congratulations on everything it's uh
thanks conan
yeah seriously i call you conan or are
we
melissa thank you so much and take care
you too